[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Please join me
in welcoming, along with her
daughter Petah, Ani DiFranco.
[APPLAUSE]
ANI DIFRANCO: Hello, hello.
Thanks.
All right, the mother
ship, pretty cool.
Oh, what's happening to me--
technical difficulties.
We'll just leave it like that.
You want to sing a tune?
This is not from
my latest record.
This is just a song that Pia
and I like to sing together.
[MUSIC, ANI AND PETAH DIFRANCO]
[APPLAUSE]
Alright.
Thank you.
Never play a guitar twice.
They get dirty.
So that was what I
was thinking when
we're singing that
song, that second verse,
have you felt the
longing in a seed?
That's you.
You're the seed that
I was writing about.
And now you're here
singing with me.
And this is a song that I
wrote for Petah's daddy.
[MUSIC, ANI DIFRANCO AND PETAH
DIFRANCO]
[APPLAUSE]
All right, thank you.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Please,
another round of applause,
Ani DiFranco and Petah DiFranco.
[APPLAUSE]
I want to thank you so much.
Thank you for the
beautiful performance
and thank you for taking
the time to come and visit
with us here in New York.
I know you have a lifelong
history here in New York.
But having relocated, you've
been spending a lot of time
back up here.
You were up here a few months
ago to receive a Lifetime
Achievement Award.
Is that correct?
ANI DIFRANCO: Right,
yes, one of those.
That's always good.
Now I can die.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
It was really
the award of a lifetime
is what I'm understanding
from your reaction.
ANI DIFRANCO: Yeah
no, that's cool.
I love coming back to New York.
I do.
I used to miss it like
a person after I left.
And now I just like to visit.
Like we were talking about,
we were talking all morning
off mic, so now we
get to talk into mics.
But yeah, now the
whole pace of New York
and just the circus of it,
I'm like wow, cool, got to go.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Well you're here now
for kind of a wild event,
supporting Cindy Lauper
and the True Colors foundation.
ANI DIFRANCO: Yeah, a benefit
to help an organization that
tries to get homeless
queer youth a place to be
and people to support them.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: It
brings me to the first topic
that I wanted to
discuss with you
which is, all of
these things speak
to a career of proactivity.
Looking back through
the years, you
have always been at the pointed
end of the proactive stick.
And I find that interesting in
the fact that a lot of artists
are very reactive.
An event would take place
and there's a response to it
or a tribute to some tragedy
or some sort of reaction based.
And I'm curious if you
can speak about what
it's been like to always be in
that proactive space instead
of just a simple reactive space?
ANI DIFRANCO: Wow, I dig it.
I dig the whole pointed
end of the stick.
I mean, yeah, jeez.
I mean I guess like
anybody I've just
been trying to speak my truth,
my experience, my thoughts,
my dreams, my perception
in my songs, in my writing.
And I guess
personally I'm always
compelled by art that
takes risks, you know?
So I've always kind
of pushed myself.
It used to be really hard
to be that in the beginning.
You know, I used to, oh jeez,
who's going to be at the show
tonight?
And no, my mom, or [INAUDIBLE]?
And what will happen
when I say this?
And a lot happens when
you're jabbing at stuff.
But I would say that the
most important thing that
happened over the years was
that people came out of nowhere
and said me too or
thank you, oh my God.
And all of that, hearing
people repeatedly
say I can't believe you
just said that, thank you,
just meant so much
more than all the rest.
So it's kind of encouraged
me to just let it go,
all those ideas of what's
private or personal or
inappropriate or
this or the other.
It's like, it's all universal.
It's, none of it's unique.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
It's curious that you
said it used to be
more difficult for you
because I would
almost think that now
is a time period of difficulty
for anyone being proactive.
There's so much tension and so
much pushback to any push that
is there.
Does that weigh in
at all when you're
about to step up and make
a bold statement of like--
you said before it
was the idea of oh,
my mom's in the
audience, I don't
want to run afoul of that.
But now some fraction
of the world might be.
ANI DIFRANCO: There's others in
the audience that are even more
dangerous than mothers.
I mean, I feel like it was
really good to just come out
of the box with my mouth and
spirit open and just start.
I mean when I was a teenager and
I started making my own songs,
I started pushing against that
wall of acceptability and what
you can and cannot say
and can and cannot be.
And really early on I
just was like, F it.
Just what's going
to happen to me?
Let's find out.
And 25, whatever it's
been, 30 years later,
I'm in a great position now.
I mean, I weeded out the
riffraff a long time ago.
I think it's much
more difficult if you
have a secret to let it go.
If you've never had
secrets, it's easier.
It's better.
People used to ask me about
coming out or this or that.
It's like, I was
not in anywhere.
And I think that that, from
my experience, it's better.
It's easier to do it that way.
I had a young lady opening
up my shows recently
who's had some success
with a song online.
And she's a lovely young gal.
And she's sort of just
embarking on a career in music.
And she was saying--
we were talking after one night
and she said, "I'm pro-choice
but I'm so afraid.
I come from a traditional
family, I this and I that."
And I said, "Just say it.
Just say it.
The sooner you say
it, the better.
Say who you are, what you
believe, what you think.
Because from there, it
gets easier every day."
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: I'm
going to change my plan now
that you brought this up because
this idea of just saying it--
I wanted to speak later in the
conversation about the idea
of directness and
metaphor, but we sort of
skipped ahead to that.
In your music there's
use of metaphor,
but where you
really get masterful
is with just direct
statements of like you said,
just taking it head on
and tackling it that way.
And I'm curious if you can talk
about the choices of when you
want to say something
in a very direct fashion
or when you reach a little
deeper for metaphor to try
and mask an idea or
bow an idea as it were.
ANI DIFRANCO: Yeah,
yeah, yeah, right.
I guess I just always had
maybe just such a burning.
Every time I see
an Eastern medicine
practitioner they say, oh, your
spleen, whoa with the spleen.
I'm like yeah, I know.
You should see my 20
records, spleen music.
And it's just, I have such an
urgent need to, I don't know,
beat back lies and
silences that often it
drives me to just say it.
I think that's just where
my music is coming from.
Sometimes I'm
interested in, how could
you say it without saying
it, or how could you say--
but oftentimes the
direct route is
what is most appealing to me.
I used to get a lot of flack for
it, like we were talking about,
a lot of resistance,
a lot of pushback.
When you were forming
your question,
I was remembering the first
time I went to Italy to play.
We were talking earlier
about touring in Europe.
And the first time I went to
Italy was probably 20 years ago
and it was in an age of
flak that I was living in.
And I remember the first
interview I did in Italy
and the dude was like, "So
many artists, they say it
but they don't say it.
They say the little metaphor.
They hint it.
You just [GRUNTS],,
you just say it."
And I was like, "That's good?
You're saying that's good?"
I'd never heard a positive
response to that before.
I just remember that so
clearly that moment of,
maybe somebody
thinks that's good.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Well, and
it's curious with the things
that you've chosen
to talk about.
And we spoke with a
little bit about this
before, as you said,
but I was immediately,
in preparing for
this conversation,
just went through
the entire catalog
again of flashing back--
ANI DIFRANCO: God
bless your heart.
Live to tell the tale.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: I'm a fan.
I'm a fan.
But a couple of things
that caught with me
were this directness.
And I mentioned before
a song like "Gratitude".
And recently of course #MeToo
has found a life online
and this sort of
understanding of women
not being alone in these
situations, and men
as well in fact.
But I immediately went
back to early '90s
when "Gratitude" spoke
exactly to that topic.
And another example would
be like "To the Teeth".
This is something that is
decades old at this point
but it's still
modern day prescient.
When something happens in the
world that you have spoken
or have tackled directly on
that flashes you back 10 years,
20 years into your career,
how does that land for you?
How does how do you
process something
like #MeToo in light of the
fact that 20 years ago you
were standing up shouting
exactly these words?
ANI DIFRANCO: Yeah, sometimes
it's a little heart sickening.
"To the Teeth"
that you mentioned
is a song about gun
violence, a song
I wrote, I don't know, pushing
20 years ago when I thought
it was completely out of hand.
So to pull that song out now and
play it is kind of devastating.
But things do change.
And often you think this
is just the way it is.
We just have to accept
this is the way it is.
And then overnight, it's not.
And this #MeToo
moment that we're in,
I think it really speaks to how
much the dominant culture sees
women now compared to when I
was writing that song even.
The fact that
we're hearing women
give voice to their experience
as though it matters,
because they're becoming
human in the dominant culture,
and now we have to
accommodate that experience
and those people and those
voices and those stories.
It's one more voice in the
chorus, one more person
with a seat at the table.
And that's incredible.
I've seen a lot change.
I've seen the work of
feminism take hold around me.
From when I was first
stomping around saying stuff
in my songs, I've never--
and I've actually,
on that tip, I've
never felt a more
receptive world around me
for a lot of my feminist ideas.
So I actually am very
hopeful right now.
I know it's a time
of great peril--
and I don't mean to underplay
that-- and a time of great pain
for a lot of people.
But I think that
the possibilities,
I think it's a
transformative moment
we're in, especially
around gender politics.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: And there's
more of that on the new album
"Binary", which by the way,
in addition to this incredibly
proactive career, it's also
an incredibly prolific career
in fact that--
I read somewhere that it's
the 20th studio album,
and I read somewhere else
that it was more than 20.
20 albums?
ANI DIFRANCO: 20, yeah,
I know, what the hell?
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
That's amazing.
ANI DIFRANCO: Yeah,
it's at least 20.
There's 20 of those suckers.
Yeah, I don't know,
a lot of songs.
Kids changed the game though.
I've slowed right down.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: But not
for lack of just still creating
amazing artwork.
There's a great album here.
And more stuff speaking to
what we were talking about,
"Immediately Play
God" jumps to mind.
Maybe you could talk about that
song and the nexus and genesis
of all that.
ANI DIFRANCO:
Absolutely, thanks.
Yeah, I mean, I started
writing that song
as kind of a bragging--
I was like, what if I was like
a cross between Howlin' Wolf
and Missy Elliott, what
would I write right now?
And I started
talking about my life
as an emancipated teenager.
I was on my own at 15,
and never got nothing
from nobody kind of.
And then the spleen took over.
And something
inside me just felt,
as I was writing this bragging
verse about how I'm not
a child, and even
when I was a child,
I didn't get a
chance to be a child.
And I was contributing
in society.
I was a part of
society real early on.
And then my brain just sort of
flicked to that to, and so you
cannot treat me like a child.
You tell me what I can and
cannot do with my body,
when I should reproduce,
if I must reproduce.
This is the kind of
way that women still
are treated in society as
though they are inferior,
as though they are children.
So I think of reproductive
freedom as a civil right.
I think that we need to
talk about it that way,
address it that way.
I think we could use another
constitutional amendment
to guarantee women civil rights.
And so the song just sort
of mutated into a women's
civil rights anthem.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
There's a lot of--
and it speaks to the title
of the album "Binary".
There's a lot of dual meaning.
And I find it interesting in
that that story started in one
place and ended in another.
Talk about the concept of
the entirety of the album
and being binary and what
that means, where that's
coming from.
ANI DIFRANCO: Yeah,
sure, here at Google.
Binary to me, first
of all, is not--
I'm not really talking
about either/or.
I'm talking about both always.
I had a run-in with the
internet a few years ago.
It came and found me in my
house and bit my head off
and chewed on it for a while.
And that was sort
of the beginning
of a lot of meditations
on consciousness for me.
Oddly, these ones and zeros
came and changed my life
and hurt me bad.
And I started to look
at the whole world
as made of
relationship, basically,
that anything that looks
to be a singularity
is really a relationship.
Everything is two
things spinning.
From our atomic structure to
the planets and the stars,
there is this fundamental
design I think
that is made of relationship.
And I'm fascinated
by quantum physics.
I don't understand
it, of course,
but I like to read about it.
And you know quantum
physicists, I
think through a long
trajectory of masculine science
have come back around to sort
of the reality of the mother
that nothing exists on its own.
Only in relationship do we--
I mean, there's an infinite
field of possibilities
until something is observed.
And they will go on to tell
you that observing something
affects it, that
observing is interacting.
So with interaction
comes existence.
I guess that's basically--
Then of course it's not
disconnected with my feminism.
And I think that that kind of--
the ways that my brain has been
spinning for the past few years
kind of weaves
through this record.
So that's why I
took that song title
to title the whole record.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Well it
goes even further than that,
because this is a very
interactive record for you,
I think, in the creation, right?
There's a lot of
collaboration on this record,
and even on the technical
side more collaboration
than I think you've
done in the past.
How was the process of making
"Binary" different or familiar
or unfamiliar or taking a risk?
ANI DIFRANCO: Yeah, well often
I make records by myself.
I crawl into a hole depending
on what's happening in my life
and make a little record.
Or I track the songs with my
band but then I futz on my own
and finish it or
something solitary.
The record right before this
I did a lot in the wee hours
when the kids were
sleeping in headphones.
This time, my youngest is four.
I needed to re-enter
the world and interact
with adults and creative
beings and people who
would bring ideas to
the table other than me.
So I tracked the tunes
with not just my core
band, rhythm section, but a few
other musicians that I love,
Ivan Neville in New
Orleans where I live
and Jenny Scheinman, a beautiful
violinist from out west.
And then I just
started calling up
a lot of other brilliant
friends that I have.
I just didn't want to be alone.
I wanted community
back in my life.
So there's a lot of
beautiful players.
And I had this kind of
experience of the best
Christmas ever again
and again where
I sent Justin Vernon a
track and then my present
comes in the mail,
bing, and I get
to open it up and see
this beautiful chorus
that he sang on my song.
It's just the most
wonderful presents came back
to me from my friends.
And then I even went
one step further
than I've ever gone which
is to have somebody else mix
the damn thing.
I've always just,
oh, I can do this.
OK, this sounds good, right?
So my records over the years
are unique and expressive.
But having brought a creative
mind like Tchad Blake
to into this project to mix it--
remotely, once again.
I just sent him raw tracks
and I got back mixes--
was breathtaking for me.
It was like, oh wow,
what if you're not crazy
and you didn't just
write the songs
and you came in with an
objectivity and a skill
that I will never
achieve in mixing?
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Different perspective.
ANI DIFRANCO: A
different perspective.
What a gift.
Wow, you can really do things
in mixing, as it turns out.
So I don't think I'll
ever go back to--
but you know, I've been
thinking about it lately,
the emancipated minor thing
when you're just, I got this,
and you're just taking
care of everything.
Now I'm 47 and I'm like, I
don't have to do that anymore.
It took me a while to let go.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
It's interesting.
It also, I found that in
listening to the record,
it's super broad in
style and approach.
And there's some stuff on
here that is very classic Ani
DiFranco style.
There are other tracks on here
that are nearly hip-hop songs.
And then "Spider" is
kind of the other end
of that spectrum in a very
indie rock kind of way.
Where did the diversity
come from from this album?
Was it out of this
collaboration or were
there trigger moments
that were like, hey,
I'm going to go in this
direction for a reason?
I'm wondering if you
could speak to that.
ANI DIFRANCO: Yeah,
I mean, I like--
and I've been hearing
it from others
that the sort of diversity
of the sounds on this record.
And I think that has to do
with Tchad and with the people
that I worked with,
the musicians helping
me translate my songs fully,
helping me manifest them fully.
I think that I've always
written really in a diverse way.
I never kind of want to
write the same song twice,
so I'm always, let
me write a song
standing on my head with
a bucket on each foot
and see what that
turns out like.
So I've done that all.
But then I think
then I just play it
like I always do on
whatever's sitting around.
And then I just sort of mix
it so you can hear everything.
But I think when other
people come in and enhance
the creativity that exists
in the seed of a song
and they say, well,
this sounds to me
like we should go over here,
and look, I have an ark.
We can go over there.
And so I think that these
songs were more fully
realized in their differences
than maybe on other records.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Well
I'm happy to hear it
because it does take a lot
of the music in a new place.
And speaking of
the new place, you
spoke a little bit of
the internet coming
to bite you a few years ago.
Skipping past that, I
know that for "Binary"
there are some videos.
And we were speaking about
it before, these were things
that you had sort of
independently done.
I wonder if you
could talk about what
it's like to be, as
we've said before,
sort of an old-school
artist approaching that way
and being thrust
into the situation
to where maybe now just
an album's not enough?
ANI DIFRANCO: Yeah,
that seems to be true.
I think I'm just a folk singer.
I'm a working musician and
playing live for people,
just gathering with people.
I think the sort of
fundamental reality of music
as a social act is
really how I feel it.
And that's what inspires me.
And so I think I'm most inspired
on stage, spending an hour
and a half, two
hours with people
and the kind of connections that
you make and the kind of less
alone that we all
feel when we walk out
of there and the kind of--
that is what I live for.
And the rest of
it, I don't know.
It's all changed around me.
And I'd be the last
to really know.
I think at one point in
the '90s people were like,
Ani, how do you do it?
Show us how it's done.
And I'm so far from
being that guy anymore.
I'm an old lady.
And I have no idea
how you utilize
the technology and the media
to have a career in music
in the 21st century.
I just know that I like
to play for people live.
And if I can just do that and
pay my rent until I'm dead,
I'll be OK.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
And you were saying
before that you
felt very flattered
by your audiences enjoying
that moment with you
and participating in
that moment with you.
I think it's very common
for people to go to shows
and the first thing that
happens is the phone comes out.
ANI DIFRANCO: Yeah, right.
We were talking
earlier this morning
and I was telling
Matthew I have noticed
this last couple of months
being on the road, no phones,
no phones in the audience,
almost no phones,
which is noticeable.
I feel like my audience
were sort of the last
to live the show
through the phone.
And when it came into the space
of my shows, I just was like,
I guess this is the world now.
There's nowhere to go that this
is not the world, so all right.
And then these last few months,
I got the feeling like people
have had enough.
They've had enough.
It's like, I want
an hour and a half
of being in a place and a time
with the people that I'm with.
And it was like,
look at you guys.
There hasn't been one
glowing blue face tonight.
"Con-grat-u-fucking-la-tions",
we're all here.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Maybe the escapism
that the phone initially
served is found again
in putting the phone
away and actually
being a part of the experience.
ANI DIFRANCO: Yeah,
well we got deep.
We got deep.
You guys missed the
whole conversation that
meant anything, because yeah--
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Well I hope not.
ANI DIFRANCO: --what
going on in new music
and who are the groundbreaking
young artists of today?
And of course
Petah will teach me
everything I need to know
eventually about that.
But we were wondering
together if this absorption
into the gizmos, this endless
distraction and entertainment
has prevented a generation or
two of groundbreaking music.
You are not bored.
You are not desperate
for connection.
So you don't have to
go into your garage
and invent some
convoluted way to connect.
But we concluded this morning,
or at least we left off with,
well, maybe we're moving past
the endless days of absorption.
Maybe that in itself is becoming
boring for young people.
So maybe that next
awesome band or artist
is right around the corner now.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Well
the speaking of next
is a good stepping-off point.
So I will say that
those of you who
have questions in the
audience, if you guys want
to make your way
to a microphone,
I encourage you to do that.
ANI DIFRANCO: Ooh, a spotlight
right by the mic there, nice.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: But
before we get into that,
I would like to talk a
little bit about next.
I know that next year has a lot
of interesting things cued up.
Specifically I think Babe
Fest is coming to New York.
ANI DIFRANCO: Yeah, possibly.
That's the big idea, Babe
Fest in Central Park.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Well that would be--
ANI DIFRANCO: Oh I know--
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: --fantastic.
ANI DIFRANCO: --I
hope, I hope, I hope.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Anybody who has
any contacts with the
SummerStage people at Central
Park--
ANI DIFRANCO: Yeah really,
put in a good word for me.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: --start
pulling your strings now.
But what else is
coming up for 2018?
ANI DIFRANCO: A book.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: A book?
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
What kind of book?
ANI DIFRANCO: Complete
sentences spelled all correctly.
I'm writing a book.
I'm trying to write a book.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Are we
talking narrative fiction
or are we talking--
ANI DIFRANCO: Yeah.
Well, we're talking memoir.
But of course it's
all made up, right?
We're all just
making up the story.
But yeah, it's an idea that
I've floated for years.
Back when I was the
groundbreaking indie girl,
the concept was more like
part manual, part memoir.
This is what happened.
Here's some tips on how--
of course that
moment is long past.
And I'm just writing stories
in a different format.
It's totally different
from songs and poems.
It's crazy to me
that it's all called
writing because it just feels
so different in its process.
But I don't know, I'm
looking for challenges
I guess as a writer.
So that's what I'm up to.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Well when you finish,
you'll have to come back
and we'll do this all again
and talk about the book.
ANI DIFRANCO: OK, cool.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Let's take
a question from the audience.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I had a bunch of questions, but
when I saw you sing with Petah,
I flashed back to 20
years ago in my hometown
seeing the late
great Chris Whitley
perform with his
daughter Trixie on stage,
probably around the
same age as Petah.
And so I'm kind of curious if
you could talk a little bit
more about the dynamics
of family and music,
who's nudging who to
perform together on stage?
How does that decision get made?
How do you draw a line
balancing exposing her
to the public on a stage to
photos versus helping her find
her own voice and her art and
her craft for about her music
future?
ANI DIFRANCO: Yeah, cool, cool.
Well I guess first of all I
start with her, what she wants.
She's been touring
with me a lot.
When she was a kid she was
a road baby until 3 and 1/2.
And so she's pro at
the touring business.
And at some point more recently
she started saying, "Momma,
I want to come
sing on that song."
OK, all right.
Don't push them on stage but say
yes if that's what they choose.
And sorry Petah that
we're talking about you,
but it made all the
difference for me
as a working musician
mom because music
was my first baby.
And the subsequent babies
that have arms and legs,
they're not well for the guitar.
They could be playing happily.
If I pick up the guitar
and try to do my thing,
they shut me down--
shut me down.
No drifting off mommy
into your world.
Me, it's about me now.
And so that was
hard as an artist.
The little guy, I have
a four-year-old son,
and he's the same way.
But as soon as Petah decided,
I want to be a part of that,
then it became our thing.
It was not my thing anymore.
And it changed the
whole atmosphere
around music, which is
just thrilling to me.
I love to sing, but I love
to sing with my daughter
even more.
So yeah, now that we can make
it something we do together,
it's opened up a
whole new era for us.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Thank
you for your question.
Let's take one from this side.
AUDIENCE: Excellent.
Hello.
ANI DIFRANCO: Hi.
AUDIENCE: First off, thank
you so much for coming.
I truly believe you are one of
the greatest poets of our time.
I don't actually a question.
This is a statement and I'm
going to embarrass myself.
I apologize.
I was one of those kids.
I grew up in rural Michigan.
I was the G in LGBT.
I didn't have anyone
to talk to you
and your music got me through.
And I would not be
here today without you.
So I just want to say thank you.
ANI DIFRANCO: Thanks man.
AUDIENCE: And I'm
going to get off
because I'm probably going to--
ANI DIFRANCO: Yeah, I'm
going to cry with you.
[APPLAUSE]
Yes, yay, yay to
realness and being
your whole authentic self.
Thank you for that
moment of vulnerability.
Yeah, I hear that a
lot and it keeps me
going through the hard moments.
That means the world to me.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Let's
take another question.
AUDIENCE: From me to
you, thank you as well.
But I want to kind of know about
how you feel about your brand.
From an external
standpoint, I kind of
see you have this
personal brand.
As I've been in this side
of you all of these years,
you now have a business brand.
You have this cultural
brand as well.
And you also now,
I'm hearing, you
have this other thing
that's mommyhood
that might prevent either the
evolution of or the building
or separation of another brand.
What does your
brand mean to you,
and can you share your
thoughts of that over time?
ANI DIFRANCO: Yeah, sure.
Let me see.
I think what I tend to
do is not think about it.
When you were talking of all
the elements in your question,
I was thinking about a story.
I hear so many wonderful
stories from people
who have intersected my
music or my brand even.
I heard a story and
I get these letters
that are just like food for
me that nourish me back.
And I got a letter
a little while ago
from a mom who is
a fan of my work.
And she had a Righteous Babe
sweatshirt with the logo.
And her young
daughter said to her,
"Mommy, is that a girl or a
boy," striking this muscle man
pose but with a skirt,
the little logo.
That started off as a
picture of me hamming it up.
I hate cameras so I'm going
to do something ridiculous.
And then that became
the logo and that
became the brand,
Righteous Babe.
So here's a little
girl who I don't
know talking to her mom who's
found something in my music.
"Mommy, is that
a girl or a boy?"
"That's a girl sweetie."
And then the little girl said,
"Is she so, so, so, so strong?"
And her mom said, "Yeah,
she's so, so, so, so strong."
And this is all in the letter.
And then she said
there was a pause
and her five-year-old said,
"I want to be like that."
And I thought, whoa, a logo.
And I don't think
that that's going
to inspire me to think about
it or how can I tweak the logo
or how can we work the brand
to make more value for--
I just try to do what
I do and be who I am
and write the best song
I can be and give it
in the most honest way
I can in whatever moment
and hope that these peripheral
things, like the idea
of Righteous Babe Records
and the look of that logo,
will do their own
work around that.
If I just stay focused on what
I know and what I'm good at,
that those peripheral things
like the Righteous Babe Brand--
I mean, we are trying to
put a festival together.
And maybe I have been
inspired by my new team
to contemplate it more, to try
to reinvent Righteous Babe.
And what does it mean to stand
at the intersection of art
and politics and who else
can we help or invite
in or what other
communities can we
help to bring closer
together, to make
stronger through a festival,
through a branded festival?
So I try to work with people
who do understand such things
and can build
momentum around them.
But for me, I just try to focus
on being an artist and a mom.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Well it's curious--
I'm going to follow
up on her question
if I can-- because the label
came out as a function of need,
right?
You created it
not to, hey, we're
going to make a ton of
money by releasing albums
but because you needed a
way to get your music out.
And I think what I
have noticed is even
with other artists on the
label, it's not out of,
hey, we're going to
put this out and make
a ton of money off of it, but
it seems to come from this music
deserves it.
And I wonder if
that functionality
speaks to what you were
saying as far as not having
to worry about
developing the brand,
just doing what
needs to get done?
ANI DIFRANCO: Yeah, one of the
great ironies of my existence,
if you're me, is this
label entrepreneur
that has followed my
name for 30 years.
And it's so not the point.
It's like so far from
the point that it
used to really bother me.
I mean of all the things that--
songwriter, activist,
entrepreneur?
OK, right, I guess I
started a record company.
But the whole point was really
to avoid the music business.
The whole point was can you
just make music your job
without having to get in
bed with business people,
bottom line-oriented people?
Not that the music industry
is full of bad people.
They're good people.
I think I was such
an idealistic kid
that it's sort of I looked at
the intersection of business
and corporate culture and art
and I see commodification.
I see everything
beautiful and vital
come out of the underground
get commodified and die.
And I thought, [GROANS].
I don't want to be a
part of that process
even if it serves me.
I find that to be such a bummer.
How else could it be done?
So the point was
really just to never--
I mean for me to just follow
my teachers, the people that
really made my world bigger and
less about myself instead of,
you should wear this and play
this song and make this happen
and here's how to--
it's just like, I don't
want to think about that.
I want to think about
something meaningful.
So yeah, I guess it was a
problem-solving process.
It was never about
running a record company
but about, how can I
dedicated as little energy
in that direction as possible?
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: We
are running close to time,
so if you guys have a
couple more questions,
we'll take them please.
AUDIENCE: All right, so that
actually dovetailed perfectly
with my question
because I'm curious,
you said you set up the record
label not out of the joy
of wanting to be
a business owner
but just to improve your direct
connection with the audience
and be able to get your
music to more people.
And I'm curious if now,
speaking of the ones and zeros,
do you feel like that's
still working or do
you feel like you're
sort of inevitably
in an embrace with Spotify,
Pandora, Apple Music, Google
Play Music, whoever?
And if you were a young
artist starting out right now,
would you try to leverage those
or would you still try and do
the whole thing yourself?
ANI DIFRANCO: I mean, there's
so much to know and navigate now
to have a career in music.
And I certainly don't think I'm
a voice of authority or knowing
necessarily.
My basic approach is to
just let go, to just let go.
As the music business and
the world changed around me,
let go of the old.
And is music free now and can
musicians have a job of music
if it's just free and you
can't commodify it at all?
And the little guy is
struggling so much.
And people have asked me what
I make about these streaming
and these--
And for me, I just
have this sort
of really basic primal
approach which is acceptance.
I can't control how
people get their music.
I just let it all happen.
And I hope that the--
and I have found through
this just sort of ignorant
but faithful approach
of, I'm going
to apply as much consciousness
as I can through my work
and hope that that comes
back at me from the universe,
hope that the universe has
a place for me in my art.
It has found a place for me.
So I'm one of the lucky ones.
Maybe it's easy for me to
speak in such trite terms
because the universe has
held me and I'm very lucky.
But I think that when you are
in the groove, when you're
in the flow of yourself,
of whoever you are
and whatever you have
to offer, there is
a place in the universe for it.
So to calculate, [GRUNTS],,
what obstacles change the flow
or guide it, I don't
worry about that.
I just worry, am I
being true to myself?
Am I giving what I have to give?
Am I listening to the
voices that guide me?
And so far it's worked out.
[LAUGHS] I don't know if
that's an answer, but--
AUDIENCE: It is.
Thank you.
ANI DIFRANCO: Thank you.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Well,
and I want to thank you.
I want to thank
you for your time
to come here and
be with us today.
I want to thank you
for your thoughtfulness
in this conversation.
It's really been a pleasure.
ANI DIFRANCO:
Likewise, thank you.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: And I hope
that everyone else will join me
in thanking you as well.
[APPLAUSE]
We are running close to
time, but I'm wondering
if you would do us the honor.
Would you mind
performing another song?
ANI DIFRANCO: Yeah,
we'll play one more.
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT:
Excellent, thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
ANI DIFRANCO: Where's
Petah, you want to sing?
Yeah, here we go.
So yeah.
So this is that song "Play
God" that we're talking about,
intergenerational feminism.
[MUSIC, ANI AND PETAH DIFRANCO,
"PLAY GOD"]
[APPLAUSE]
MATTHEW HENDERSHOT: Please
keep the applause going.
Ani DiFranco, Petah DiFranco,
thank you both very much.
[APPLAUSE]